ils n'ont pas dormi de la nuit à 2
heures du matin réveillé par les flammes
ses habitants du bois du verne on
regardait impuissant leur voiture partir
en fumée
j'attendais des grands bouts j'ai ouvert
la fenêtre et j'ai vu qu'il y avait
marqué pour les feu à une voiture balai
il se trouve elle dit prenez feu après
la mienne et après ensuite des autres
voitures qui a eu plus qu'à pris feu
hier par commande pourquoi quitter café
ça l'était moins par crainte de
représailles sont rares a accepté de
s'exprimer depuis le premier étage ce
jeune homme a vu l'auteur de l' incendie
s'enfuir il y avait une personne grandes
personnes debout qui regardaient je me
suis dit ça c'est pendant moi je suis
descendu au couvent enfin mon collègue
on est descendu le temps que je vous la
porte que shirt il m'a entendu je lai
poursuivie au courant montre de poche
trop claquette
j'ai rien pu faire mon collègue j'ai
donné mes clés je ferai ma voiture il a
d'ailleurs le mot voiture pendant que
poursuivre l autre est ballotté cic
barré y avait une voiture qui
l'attendait le city et il a détalé les
ventes et en effondrant les voitures
mais j'aurais choper le cas on aurait
défoncé au pied de l'immeuble les
résidents refont le récit de la nuit et
partagent leurs angoisses
tellement que j'ai peur j'ai dormi dame
en voiture ça lui je me suis mis
derrière la chute a moins peur à partir
vers 2 heures du matin avec une couette
avec une grande torche et puis quand kim
abri ont répété de sûreté la nuit voilà
ce qu'on disait y avait des gamins qui
avaient peut-être 12 ans qu'est ce qui
sert trop salé ni du matin deux anges
pour rassurer ses administrés marie
claude jarrot maire de montceau a
réclamé l'instauration d'un couvre-feu
pour mineurs dès ce soir
en plus d'un renfort policier dès ce
soir nous avons le renfort d'une demi
compagnie de crs 1 c'est l'équivalent de
35 ans 1re police plus ses équipages
départementaux qu'il s'agisse des bas
que les unités canines ou des renforts
même du groupe de sécurité de proximité
du creusot donc ils vont venir
patrouiller sur la circonscription et on
va essayer de maintenir ce dispositif
autant que nécessaire
une enquête est en cours adultes ou
mineures le profil des auteurs reste à
cette heure indéterminée